in kentucky the death toll is up to at
least 37 from some of the worst flooding
the state has ever seen crews are
desperately searching for survivors in
areas that are very hard to reach right
now justin michaels from our partners at
the weather channel is in hard hit
whitesburg kentucky
dramatic video from last week's storms
show a group of men rescuing a
98-year-old grandmother trapped with her
family
i can see her face neighbors in this
whitesburg community battled fast moving
flood waters to get may amberge and
others to safety
rescues like these are happening across
the eastern part of the state as
emergency teams search for survivors
by air and boat the national guard alone
has rescued over a thousand people fish
and wildlife got a chance to thank them
for all those rescues and
they're the ones finding most of the
bodies so make sure they're taking care
of themselves
one of the worst flooding events in
state history has killed more than three
dozen among the victims four children
all siblings swept away from their
parents
hundreds are still unaccounted for the
one in a thousand year rain event wiped
out entire communities the whole entire
house like the walls was caving in like
there was water coming through the walls
thousands of survivors like sierra jones
and samantha tubbs are cleaning up what
the power of water left behind it
doesn't even seem real it's
none of this seems real the whole county
it just feels like a nightmare
so today search and rescue teams will
continue the search for the unaccounted
for also this morning the flood watch
expires at 9 a.m at present we have blue
skies of course a little bit of good
news for those searchers also for the
families hundreds of families still
wanting their loved ones back governor
andy beshear says that effort could take
weeks nate there is more rain in the
forecast later this week
our heart goes out to those in kentucky
hopefully as a country we can band
together and give our resources to help
justin michaels thank you